يتحدث عن تكبير الروسي خسائر فاتحه
تحذير اممي من تعرض قرابه ثمانيه ملايين
طفل في سوريا وتركيا للخطر بسبب الزلزله
جوندد بتجارب الصواريخ الباليستيه كوريا
الشماليه واليابان تدعو مجلس الامن لبحث
الازمه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كشف رئيس لجنه تحقيق الروسيه
الكسندر باستريكين عن جمع ادله تثبت تورط
القياده العسكريه والسياسيه لاوكرانيا في
الاباده الجماعيه لسكان دومباس اكد ايضا
استعدادا اللجنه لتقديم نتائج التحقيق
وعرضها في المحكمه من صور ووثائق وشهود
تثبت تورط النظام الاوكراني في ارتكاب
جرائم ضد الانسانيه على حد قوله
رئيس الاوكراني ان جيش بيلاد ويلحق سائره
كبيره للغايه بالقوات الروسيه قرب بلده
فاهيلدار في منطقه دومباس الشرقيه واضاف
زينسكي انه كلما تكبد الروس الخسائر في
دون باس كلما اتجهت الحرب نحو نهايتها
الوضع معقد للغايه هناك نحن نقاتل ونحطم
الغزاه ونلحق بروسيا خسائر فادحه اكرر
مرارا وتكرارا كلما زادت الخسائر التي
تكبدتها روسيا هناك في دومباس في مخموت
وفوليدار ومارينكا وكريمينا كلما تمكنا من
انهاء هذه الحرب بشكل اسرع بانتصار
اوكرانيا
نذهب الان لنتابع انطلاق فعاليات منتدى
الرياض الدولي الانس
بنيه تحتيه خضراء واشياء اخرى خضراء ولكن
الاشخاص
شيء هام على سبيل المثال
المزارعون في الساحل يجب ان يكون لديهم
الخبره والتمكين والمساعده
والذين تحدث عنه الان وهو
قاعه او الجبل السليجي هو تكون في القطاع
الخاص اذا نكتفي بهذا القدر من النسخه
الثالثه التي انطلقت منذ قليل من منتدى
الرياض الدولي
للانسان من مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه
والاعمال الانسانيه
متابعه ان نشر افادت صحيفه فاينل تايم زان
الرئيس البولنديه اندريدا دعا دول حلف
شمال الاطلس الى تقديم ضمانات امنيه
لاوكرانيا بعد الصراع مشيرا الى ان ذلك
سيرفع معنويات الجنود الاوكرانيين
باستشعار دعم
خلال فتره الحرب تفرض حراسه مشدده على
زعماء البلدان المتحاربه الامر لا يختلف
بالنسبه للرئيسين الروسي والاوكراني بين
قطار بوتين المدرع ومخبئ زيلينسكي السري
تباينت وسائل الحمايه في وقت تستمر
المعارك الضاريه
قطار بوتين المدرع وملجا تحت الارض بين
كياف وموسكو اختلفت وسائل الحمايه المخصصه
لزعيم البلدين زمن الحرب بوتين يستعمل
القطار خلال تنقلاته في جميع انحاء روسيا
والوصول الى قصوره الخاصه القطار مطلي
باللونين الاحمر والرمادي ما يجعله كاي
قطار ركاب عادي هو عباره عن عربه رئاسيه
بها غرفه نوم بالاضافه الى مقصوره مجهزه
بمعدات الاتصالات المتطوره كلف بناؤه اكثر
من 13 مليون دولار يقال ان الرئيس الروسي
مقتنع بان السفر فيه اكثر امانا من ركوب
الطائرات التي يسهل تتبعها الحكايه مختلفه
في كييف زيليسكي يحتمي تحت الارض في مخبا
سري يطلق عليه اسم بانكوفا وهو كتله
خرسانيه من المكاتب المحاطه بحلقه من
الفولاذ تصطف حوله نقاط التفتيش مع حراس
المسلحين لا يسمحون بدخول اي شخص سوى من
لديهم تصريح بذلك ويطلب الجنود من
الموجودين كلمات مرور سريه تتغير يوميا
وغالبا ما تكون عبارات يصعب على الروس
نطقها استخدمه واعضاء حكومته خلال سيطره
الجيش الروسي على بلدات مجاوره بعد ذلك
تغيرت الخطه وخرج زيلينسكي ومن معه بلال
الوجداني العربيه
مصادر مطلعه لوكاله الانباء الروسيه
ريانوفسكي بان روسيا وتركيا قد تجددان
المفاوضات حول اتفاق تصدير الحبوب من
البحر الاسود برعايه امميه ووفق المصادر
فان المناقشات المنتظره ستعقد قريبا من
اجل توسيع مبادره حبوب البحر الاسود ولان
روسيا غير راضيه عن بعض جوانب الصفقه
وكانت موسكو قد انتقدت الامم المتحده
لفاشرها في الوفاء بالتزاماتها في الاتفاق
بشان تسهيل الصادرات الزراعيه الروسيه الى
الدول التي تحتاجها
يزور وزير خارجيه الصين وانجي موسكو اليوم
بعد جوله اوروبيه اعلن خلالها عن خطه
صينيه للسلام في اوكرانيا ووفقا للمتحدث
باسم وزارات الخارجيه الصينيه فان زياره
وانجيلي روسيا ستوفر فرصه للبلدين لمواصله
تطوير الشراكه الاستراتيجيه وتبادل وجهات
النظر حول القضايا الدوليه والاقليميه ذات
الاهتمام المشترك ولم تحدد وزاره الخارجيه
ما اذا كان الوزير الصيني سيلتقي بالرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
نعود الى منتدى الرياض الدولي الانساني في
نسخته الثالثه لمتابعه فعاليه لست جيدا ان
يكون من
الاحياء من السياسيه والشيء الاخير اتمنى
ان ارى السلام في اليمن
خلال سنتين انا اريد ان احل كل الصراعات
وان نتمكن من فعل هذا وان نزيد مجتمع
التبول التبرع
والنعزز الرقمنه
والذكاء الاصطناعي وجمع البيانات وتحسين
الوضع الاوليات بناء على البراهين
اتى اامل لشيء واحد هو ان فجوه التمويل
الانساني سوف تتقلص وتختفي وهذا يمكن ان
يحدث بطريقتين اساسيتين الاول ان نزيد
التمويل عن طريق توسيع
قائده البيانات والشيء الاخر عن طريق
تقليل المساعدات الانسانيه عن طريق منع
النزاعات وحل القائمه
اتمنى ان نرى تركيزا اكبر وان نرى تعاونا
اكثر لان التحديات هائله
والمصادر محدوده
هل اظهرتم تقديركم للاعضاء
وايضا من اجل تغلبنا على المشاكل تقنيه في
الصوت
تغادرون القاعه ونبدا الجزء الثاني من
الحوار
اذا تبعنا جانبا من مناقشات منتدى الرياض
الدولي الانسانيه كان هناك كلمه للمبعوث
الاممي مارتن جرافيث سنذكر بانه مركز
الملك سلمان للاغاثه ينظم هذا المنتدى
اعلنت منظمه الامم المتحده للطفوله
يونيسيف عن تعرض حوالي 2.5 مليون طفل
الخطري في سوريا وما يتجاوز 4.5 مليون طفل
في تركيا بسبب الزلزال يوسف اوضحت ايضا ان
عائلات هؤلاء الاطفال تواجه ظروفا صعبه
ناجمه عن كارثه طبيعيه دون مساكن ايوائيه
وفرص عاليه للاصابه بالكوليرا كما اكدت
مواصله تقييم الوضع وتحديد المخاطر
المحتمله في تركيا في سوريا وت
[موسيقى]
ركيا
بامكاني اليوم ان اعلن باننا وفرنا مئه
مليون دولار اخرى لمساعده الاشخاص الذين
في امس الحاجه اليها لقد جلبنا هذا المبلغ
من صندوق الطوارئ للاجئين والهجره وكذلك
من صندوق المساعده الانسانيه التابع
لوزاره الخارجيه والوكاله الامريكيه
للتنميه الدوليه
في تركيا يعيش سكان الاحياء العتيقه
بمدينه اسطنبول حاله خوف من حدوث زلزال
محتمل وفق ما اعلنه خبراء فيما اطلقت
سلطات البلديه انذارا تحذيريا عاجلا
لاصحاب ما يزيد عن 100 الف بنايه هشه من
اجل فحصها والتاكد من سلامتها
مع كل هزه ارتداديه جديده يشعر بها
الاتراك تهتز معها قلوب سكان هذه الاحياء
والاف من قاطني بنايات وصف عمده اسطنبول
هياكلها بالخطيره
انها مساله حياه او موت هكذا حذرت سلطات
اسطنبول السكان هنا داعيه اصحاب البنايات
الهشه والقديمه الى الاسراع في فحسها
وهناخذ عيني الي تركي من اصول عربيه يعيش
بهذه البنايه المتصدعه في حي الفاتح منذ
سنوات في تشققات
الفاتح وعندي هون تشققات بس فوق وانا ما
بقول لك ما في خوف في خوف بس شلون الوضع
عم بطل لبره مثلا اليوم صار شيء
كل ما يشغل باله هذه الايام هو كيفيه
انقاذ عائلته في حال تحركت الارض
والله يسترنا اذا كان وضع مثلا بدي يهدوا
يهدوا الحكومه وانا بقرف
كل واحد خايف على اولادها غير الله سبحانه
وتعالى وهالاولاد
احصت بلديه اسطنبول ما يزيد عن 100 الف
بنايه بحاجه عاجله الى فحص ضوئي واوسط
باتخاذ قرارات صارمه لانقاذ ملايين
الارواح في ظل توقعات خبراء بحدوث زلزال
هائل خلال السنوات القادمه
نحن نتوقع ان يحدث زلزال اخر قد لا يكون
مركزه في اسطنبول لكنها ستتضرر كثيرا
خصوصا واننا لم نحضر جيدا لذلك فكثير من
البنايات غير مطابقه للزلازل ويجب اعاده
النظر سريعا في معايير البناء
توقعات زادت من ارباك الناس مع تواتر
مخلفات الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب جنوب
البلاد
بالتاكيد نخاف من البنايات القديمه لو
ازيلت لكان افضل لذلك نطالب السلطات
بالتحرك قبل فوات الاوان يعني متعرضين اي
ساعه او دقيقه شي يصير زلزال في عنا في
تركيا في اسطنبول يعني واذا صار في
اسطنبول بده يصير كارثه كبيره يعني
ما عم نحسن
وامام هذا الوضع تسابق السلطات التركيه
الزمن لبحث حلول استباقيه قد تجنب البلاد
تكرار كارثه زلزال الجنوب الذي لم يتوقف
بعد عداد ضحاياه رغم تجاوزه الاربعين الف
قتيل عبد القادر خربوش العربيه اسطنبول
عقد وزير الداخليه السعوديه الامير عبد
العزيز بن سعود جلسه مباحثات رسميه مع
وزير الداخليه العراقي الفريق اول ركن عبد
الامير كامل الشمري جرى خلال الجلسه بحث
سبل تعزيز التعاون الامني بين وزارتي
الداخليه في البلدين كما شهدت الجلسه
توقيع مذكره التفاهم للتفاهم والتفاهم
الامني بين الجانبين وشملت مذكره تفاهم
جميع اشكال التعاون الامني وتبادل الرؤى
وتفعيل العمل الامني المشتركي مما يضمن
المزيد من الامن للجانبين العراقي
والسعودي
نشرتنا مستمره فيها بعض الفاصل ايران تنفي
تقسيم اليورانيوم بنسبه تزيد عن 60%
اهلا بكم من جديد من المقرر ان يعقد مجلس
الدوله الليبيه اليوم جلسه رسميه في
طرابلس لبحث التعديل الدستوري الذي اقره
مجلس النواب واكدت مصادر من المجلس
للعربيه ان من اهم بنود الجلسه بعد مناقشه
التعديل الدستوري استكمال تفاصيل المناصب
السياسيه
اخر كشف رئيسه مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقيه
موسى فقي محمد ان المنظمه ستنظم مؤتمرا
بشان المصالحه الوطنيه في ليبيا في احدث
محاوله لاعاده الاستقرار للبلاد وقال ثقي
في مؤتمر صحفي اختتمت به قمه الاتحاد
الافريقي ان لقاءات تمت مع مختلف الاطراف
والمنظمه بصدد العمل معهم لتحديد موعد
ومكان لعقد المؤتمر الوطني الذي سيلتئم
برعايه لجنه رفيعه المستوى من الاتحاد
الافريقي يتراسها الرئيس الكونغولي
دينيسيا
دعت الامينه العامه للاتحاد الاوروبي
للنقابات الرئيسه التونسي قيس سعيد
الاحترام لحقوق الانسان والتوقف عن
استهداف النقابات وذلك بعد يوم من طردها
من البلاد لمشاركتها في احتجاج مناهض
للحكومه نظمه اتحاد الشغل التونسي احد
اكبر القوى في البلاد كما قالت ليش انها
سترفع معامله السلطات التونسيه لها الى
اعلى المستويات في الاتحاد الاوروبي
نفت منظمه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه ما
تردد عن تخصيبها لليورانيوم بنسبه 84
بالمئه والقريبه من درجه نقاوه صنع
الاسلحه النوويه وفقا لتقرير وكاله
بلومبرج فان هذه المره الثانيه التي تقوم
بها ايران بهذه
الانشطه في مرده المتحدثه وقال فعديان
المتحدث باسم منظمه الطاقه الذريه
الايرانيه ان بلاده لم تقم حتى الان باي
محاوله لتخصيب اليورانيوم بالنسبه تزيد عن
60% مؤكدا على ان وجود جزيئات تزيد نسبه
التخصيب فوق 60% لا يعني الانتاج بتخصيب
اعلى من هذه النسبه ووفقا لتقرير كما
ذكرنا فان هذه المره الثانيه التي يكتشف
فيها المراقبون هذه الانشطه المشبوهه التي
تتعلق بالتخصيب اليورانيوم في منشات نوويه
ايرانيه
قالت كوريا الجنوبيه ان اطلاق جارتها
الشماليه المتكرره لصواريخ استفزاز خطيره
يقود الامن الدولي من جهه قال كبير امناء
مجلس الوزراء الياباني هيروكازو ماتسونو
بشده تجربه الصاروخيه الاخيره لكوريا
الشماليه مؤكده
قرارات مجلس الامن وتهدد السلامه وامن
الياباني والمنطقه
اطلقت كوريا الشماليه اليوم قرابه الساعه
السابعه صباحا صاروخين باليسيين قصي المدى
باتجاه الشرق بالقرب من الساحل الغربي
لكوريا الشماليه اطلاق الصاروخين ينتهك
ايضا قرارات مجلس الامن ذات الصله وقدمت
اليابان احتجاجا شديدا على كوريا الشماليه
وادانا ذلك بشده سلسله الاجراءات التي
تتخذها كوريا الشماليه تهدد سلامه وامن
اليابان والمنطقه والمجتمع الدولي وهي غير
مقبوله على الاطلاق
الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
غوتيري بالتجربه الصاروخيه التي اجرتها
كوريا الشماليه نهايئه الاسبوع دايا الى
الكافي فورا عن الاعمال الاستفزازيه ووفقا
المتحدث باسم بوتيرش ادانا الامين العام
بشده اطلاقا كوريا الديمقراطيه الشعبيه
صاروخا بالستيان اخر من مدن عابر للقارات
مشددا على امتثال الامم المتحده
الالتزاماتها الدوليه بموجب جميع قرارات
مجلس الامن ذات الصله واستئناف الحوار
المؤدي الى السلام المستدامى واخلائي شبه
الجزيره الكوريه من الاسلحه النوويه
افاد مراسل العربيه بحدوث اشتباكات عنيفه
بين حرس الحدود الباكستاني وقوات طالبان
في معبر تورخام بيباكستان بحسب المصدر سبب
النزاع غير واضح وطلب من السكان اللجوء
الى اماكن امنه مع استمرار الحرب بين
الجانبين باستخدام الاسلحه الخفيفه
والثقيله
تسببت الفيضانات وانهيارات التربه الناجمه
عن الامطار الغزيره بمقتل 36 شخصا على
الاقل في ولايه ساو باولو بحسب سلطات
البرازيليه ودمرت احياء باكملها وغمرها
الماء وحطام منازل جرفتها التربه وطرقا
سريعه غارقه وسيارات دمرتها اشجار متساقطه
مع مواصله عمال الانقاذ البحث عن ضحايا
وعمل اكثر من مئه من عناصر الاطفاء في
الموقع بمساعده المروحيات
اعدت جثه اللاعب الغني كريستيانو اتسو الى
منزله في اكرا بعد يوم من العثور عليه
ميتا تحت مبنى منها في جنوب تركيا واعتبر
الصوفي اعداد المفقودين منذ زلزال السادس
من فبراير بعد انهيار مبنى سكني فيها تاي
حيث كان يعيش
نهايه النشره تذكير بابرز
موسكو تتهميه
من تعرض قرابه 8 ملايين طفل في سوريا
وتركيا للخطر بسبب الزلزال
يندد بتجارب الصواريخ الباليستيه لكوريا
الشماليه واليابان تدعو مجلس الامن لبحث
الازمه
القاكم على راس الساعه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]